hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to honey camstudio I
changed up my hair so that's flowing
like Phoenix right and eventually I'll
play a game like Phoenix right and then
have this hair but anyway so we're
making a lot of money now so I'm going
to pull Jesse off of shopping Beauty we
need to get another girl in here and
she's gonna be the new shopper because
jesse is now has a lot of fans for some
reason I don't know where that happened
but she got a lot of fans so shove this
up your butt and then we're gonna get
another girl in here but that means we
got to recruit another one digging is
doing it okay and we got to collect more
money more fastly and it just changed
over so I gotta buy the new ads ah oh I
thought I could get them all or whatever
good enough
okay Kiana you need to finish up your
training you need to go shopping for
more cigarettes you need to earn more
malevolent dollars yes I think I'm doing
way better than I did in last one I'm
not sure it's very hard to say because
in the last one I was clicking like a
maniac
but I wasn't capitalizing on like the
this dressing out of it or the spreading
out of the fetishes and whatnot god I
I'm worried cuz I'm getting used to
saying that and then it's gonna become
commonplace for me and it sounds so
dirty it's so dirty I don't like it
mmm okay so then one more chubby and
then your twos dressed you need to get
more of these so everyone else stays
unstressed you got that um then she's
too stressed which means that we got a
lot of problems so we have let me see
this again okay we don't have furry ears
so that's what we need and then you are
going into the drink you're gonna be
tossed in a river and then bathed
repeatedly to wash the sorrow out of
your skin and then we'll move forward
and be happy and fun and free okay so
now we need a [ __ ] anymore
baby baby
no you cannot be done now why are you
giving me so much attitude you're making
thousands and thousands of dollars so
much money oh I gotta get this before we
do that I need to make sure that
everybody else is maxed out in terms of
shrimp attention that's a weird way of
putting it I shouldn't put it that way
so you're doing that okay so you're done
there you're now a good moneymaker we do
that maximum capacity so we need to
increase the capacity add dingus dammit
more money more money more money and
then this and then hopefully before the
next cycle tomorrow we have enough so
that we can have people know nothing
else for now no I'm not happy I need
more my external curse is that I always
need more I'm never satisfied with what
I have
oh god the therapist isn't our lawyer
okay thank you go back in thank you go
back in thank you go back in non stop
let's place no matter what I don't care
how raw your voice is I don't care how
tired you are you get back on that
camera you do more Let's Plays okay
everybody hold off on doing the cam
shows just yet okay hello you are all
different who are you people I don't
know who you are Sarah is an unbearable
weeaboo who thinks she's Japanese and
calls herself Suki she's the worst but
she's still kind of hot in that weird
way
Renee escaped her hometown and moved out
west to fulfill her dream of becoming an
actress she's working her way up you
gotta start somewhere and Brooke Brooke
is a wife mother and businesswoman who
seeks out attention online from young
men because her boring husband leaves
her drier than a desert well isn't that
romantic who do we pick we don't have
anymore huniepop character so we got to
pick from everybody else apparently I
mean of these three the stats kind of go
for Sarah but also oh man she her pay
rate is way too high
I mean ah burns she's got the most fans
and she's got the least pay so I'm gonna
go with that
all right oh god what the hell oh god
what have I done
shut up oh my god what have I done okay
that's good I guess oh okay so you're
gonna get the furry thing a butt plug
you're gonna get whatever we got you did
this shove this up you take that wow you
5000 fans oh my god we're way high in
the fan metrics okay but this good so
you need training she needs a lot of
training before she's gonna be able to
do what she needs to do ooh payroll
processed that means that we got new
promotional items which is good we'll
get more money later because we've got
everyone literally everyone is in the
cam chill right now well not literally
everyone I'm a liar that was a lie but
figuratively a lot of people are in the
cam show right now 20 with Lola's level
5 so it's good the only thing that I've
learned is that it doesn't it doesn't
retro actively apply so if you do it
halfway through doing a cam show it
won't it won't give you more money it's
unfortunate like that hold on I think go
back in make sure you're done you're
never done until you're dead I'm a very
strict owner owner I don't own anyone
here I want to be very clear about that
I don't own anyone 100% totally legit m2
operation here don't need to worry about
a thing
yeah I will okay have fun
okay promotion whoo now we're getting
into the heavy items yes more fans okay
21,000 fans on day 14 that we means we
get a week of like exponential growth to
make sure that everyone gets as many
fans as possible it doesn't matter that
there's overlap it just matters how many
days left to buy fans because
there's no way you literally cannot get
more fans through photo shoots you can't
do it it's not gonna help you in the
long run
it won't be enough no matter what you do
no matter what you try see not gonna be
enough gee guys you good I don't know
shut up
oh my fingers are starting to hurt too
much ah what they called the game
finger-blasted that's literally the
terminology that they use not what I use
they call it finger blastin and I have
no idea what that means cuz I'm an
innocent little boy and I don't want to
even know about anything to do with
being a grown up so we're gonna shut up
about it and no one's gonna be none the
wiser
ooh I haven't No okay so you're now my
errand girl so you're always gonna be
doing these things the only problem is
she always needs to be kind of like yeah
you know I just realized the absolute
magnitude of the horrible person that I
am god damn it we just have to buy this
so that we can get more money out it's
so stupid
I have to buy more to get more money
god damn it okay this is where things
get kind of juggle II like not not jump
you juggle a lot in this part of the
game because you end up just like
spazzing out about putting people into
different places and getting them in the
right spots at the right times that you
don't really have time to think about
anything else
pretty much everything from this point
on it's just dedicated towards one task
and that is simply getting more money
get more fans to get more money to get
more fans to get more money to get more
fans right now we're at 35,000 fans we
need a lot more money to get a lot more
fans oh you did so good I suppose maybe
yes there it is okay so now I guess you
make you make too much money to be
dodging that one but as soon as um as
soon as Tiffany's out of there Tiffany's
gonna be back into the air and girl
because that's what she do
that's how we do kinda mean just how we
do it everyone's cam showing how proud I
am of this moment where everyone's
working together it's so much easier
when she's coked out of her mind oh it
sounds so bad I'm such an [ __ ] it's
such a horrible person oh it's not good
okay we got to get this okay that's
maxed she's there
there we go that's much better now I
don't have to worry about so much stuff
going on my own I mean I still have to
worry about you know doing doing my own
thing by myself but eventually it'll all
be handled why are you so stressed out
what did you do you need to go into
training if you need just a little bit
more you're done you're done you're done
you got it I'm the man with the plan
everyone's good okay so we got that okay
you get this late game stuff do you have
your you're all hopped up okay see you
there you are stressed apparently why
are you stressed you really don't need
to be stressed right now okay my clique
finger my finger blaster MA my blasting
finger is very tired so I'm just gonna
go back to holding
because goddamn if I don't have time to
do everything else
yeah BQ more fans ah god damn it we need
so much more money so much more money
yes I do I need to reevaluate what
everybody has okay so you have ten
thousand nine thousand fourteen ten
seven seventeen thousand so you have the
most fans and is that because Oh which
one of these are the most it is ah yeah
okay so apparently ah that's way down so
you can get rid of that you don't need
this you can take that out here but
apparently take one of these seriously
and yeah okay then boink boink boink
okay got all those all those are taken
care of we're getting a lot of money
we're getting a lot of money level five
rushing which is way better way way way
better okay belly stress out but now
everyone's cycling to be stressed out
yet everyone's got to go in everyone's
got to go in I know I know it's all like
synced up it's all synced up we don't
need to worry about it's fine what I
want to know is where the male cam men
where's the cam get guys I don't know
like I'm not one that's too
knowledgeable about the whole cam world
but it has to exist right it must that
must be a thing cam guys is it I don't
know I don't know if you guys know but I
don't want to know if you guys know so
let's just keep that to ourselves and
calm everything down a little bit okay
everyone's coming out of the stress
cycle which means that everyone's going
back in to make men's Lance of men's go
back in complete oh wow okay these are
now getting ludicrously expensive which
means that we're approaching the final
few days here we only have four days
left which is good and bad so now we
need to start getting desperate about
money okay we cleared out this day and
it took 3:30 and my hand is cramped up
like you wouldn't believe
my fingers are hurting my fingers my
poor fingies but I'm gonna take a little
break I'm gonna end this episode here
and then we're gonna continue this in
just a final episode in the final panic
drive to the end of this game which
there is not much longer left you know
what actually screw that there's not
much left long I'm gonna take a little
breather and I'm gonna get right back
into it
I'm not gonna let a little thing like
broken bones and arthritis get in the
way my victory and my girls we're gonna
make it yeah if there's one thing that
I've learned from playing this game is
that these girls should ask for a raise
because holy crap all this money is
going to that fairy and none of it's
going to me I'm not making a goddamn
cent off of this so it's a rip off for
everybody
volved then why the hell why the hell is
everybody not asking for more money they
don't even have their little piggy bank
is an excuse what are they gonna do we
only got three days left Oh God
hi guys everybody is actually some
desperation tactics involved in the end
of the game because when you send these
lovely ladies into the hotel to search
for money underneath mattresses they
have run the risk of being bitten by a
radioactive spider and then being
subjected to a horrible STD spider
transmitted disease that's gonna be
debilitating them but it's an endgame
tactic because you just send everybody
in there ah because what's the risk if
it does happen anyway so screw them over
for the rest of their life or this stuff
it's so bad I don't know lots lots
months god damn I need more money
god damn it need more money me more
money money money yeah yeah at least I
cleared through oh no I didn't clear
through the risk god damn it
you gotta get these last two oh man I'm
not gonna have enough ah damn it
desperation tactics are gonna have to
come in sooner than I thought cuz I'm
not gonna clear I gotta clear through
this I gotta clear through it I gotta
clear through it I want to clear through
it I want to clear through it No ah damn
it not enough
I didn't clear through the list damn it
three day left we didn't make it we
didn't have enough money we didn't have
enough money damn it god damn it I need
to spend so much money just to be able
to pull the money out to be able to
spend more time clicking on them to make
them go faster in their jobs so in the
end the tally doesn't matter how much
money you have or how many like what
specific type of fans you have it just
matters fans you need fans you need a
lot of fans you need more fans and you
can count you need as many fans as you
can hole
dhannu desperately and then you just go
about your day having fun isn't
everybody having fun I'm about to engage
desperation tactics in the next move
that I make it's gonna be bad it's gonna
start to get ugly it's gonna be
compromising a lot of morals time for
desperation you know what that means
checking under those mattresses extra
hard even in the dangerous places okay
desperation involves just repeatedly
dropping them on the sleazy hotel and
hoping for the best because what else
can you up jump them up Jesse got there
we go at least you can still go work
there and that's what matters okay but I
can't keep everyone there I only have
two days left so I need to keep like a
like a distribution of everyone doing
but I got tons of Mines okay so this is
good
AB AB AB AB yes okay this is better okay
that's two of my girls down but at least
they can still go do cameras TIFF want
to protect some of their innocence
though from those horrible spiders those
damn spiders you know they get
everywhere it's not good okay Audrey no
both of them - two - god damn it oh
that's not good well at least they'll be
stuck camming for a while time for the
ultimate finger blasting possible it's
the final countdown oh I'm gonna beat my
record I'm gonna be my record oh I'm
gonna be my record I am going to be my
record I just gotta go hard I gotta go
from oh boy boy
yes cleared the board okay we cleared
the board that's what I wanted to do
that's what I needed to do it's all good
now we'll actually a be able to get
ahead quite a bit for tomorrow cuz
tomorrow is the last day that we're
gonna be able to buy him so tomorrow is
the last day that we're gonna be able to
get any sort of fans so we just need
money
we just need money last day coming up we
got it
we're rolling we got it so much months
ah my hand hurts so badly so badly but
it's the final day I got a go for it
I got a go for it I got a go for the
gold I gotta go for the diamond the
diamond dick again gonna beat the record
on the diamond deck okay last day so
well gotta gotta pull out all the stops
here and hope for the best hope it's not
gonna be the rest I know that for a fact
yep damn damn got hepatitis that means
ah [ __ ] ah that's that's the bad one
that's that's the one that you can't do
camming and of course it was the one
girl that all right okay you just do you
think we gotta do it I want to save
Nikki though I don't want Nikki to go
get a spider-bite
that would be no good oh I know what she
could do oh I actually do know what she
could do she could go browse and
hopefully there's like a steroid shot
and with a steroid shot you actually
have a chance of her not a chance Wow
cleared the board yeah oh my god that's
that's it then
that's as much as we're gonna get
because going in to do photo shoots is
not gonna work cuz it won't get anything
this is like 30 fans is a drop in the
bucket oh man Wow
I didn't expect that to work I guess I'm
done then what the hell that's weird
what
that's weird we're done then there's
there's no way to get more what I get to
save Nicki yeah I don't have the subject
are two horrible spiders yeah I mean
there's literally nothing else that I
can do huh that's interesting
fascinating I guess everyone I I guess I
could just pile everyone into the
relaxation spa and just give everyone a
day off I mean job well done everyone
everyone can just relax
there's nothing else to do I guess I can
just let everyone sit and be bygones I
guess I'm gonna go peacefully into the
night we're just gonna we're just gonna
all chill but you got a chill we got
enough smokes and drinks to last us the
rest of the night it's cool we're just
we're just hanging out I get to spend
time with girls are you to beat him you
guys talk to me they're gonna say hi me
oh my god hey when you're having fun
doesn't it it's your new okay I did
pretty good click anywhere you continue
yeah that's a lot of Kim I let plays
that's a lot of thumbnails made that
Laura yoga points gotten anyway don't
drink or smoke I won't tell you how to
live your life otherwise and that but
whatever
most profitable girl was Kiana nice most
expensive girls Lola that's to be
expected errand girl was Tiffany most
popular fetish was fit most popular girl
was Audrey apparently Wow nice bottle oh
this is gonna take forever
Matt censor that censor it I said censor
it
Matt sighs are that more than that more
than the last one
Matson is that even more oh my god Matt
sighs oh good lordy Center every part of
that more censorship coming in from the
left right up and down censor censor
censor guys yeah I know thank you thank
you you truly are the master of putting
girls on buildings I sure AM in the real
world
oh great Oh Doku all thank you around in
this file just for fun that's cool no I
don't anything no I'm not gonna do that
again try to beat your score and earn
some more wardrobe token no I don't
think I need to do that either because
I've done this enough okay cool great
have fun
hello how are you doing there okay so
the only other thing to show you guys is
the Wardrobe which is the different
things that you can get for different
outfits and once you max out an outfit
you get a special bonus picture that's
kind of creepy and I don't know why
anyone went on to see it all so there
you go
I have belly I've been given belly your
outfits and no I don't have a problem I
talk to real girls okay but that is
unique am studio I beat it if you can
beat my high score more power to you
because I know there's some people that
are crazy out there and there was a new
harder difficulty those set in the game
so try for yourself if you feel like it
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know how I did in the comments
below
if you enjoyed this playthrough I would
love to know your thoughts so thanks
again and as always I will see you in
the next video I'll get you